Translator: Andrea McDonough
Reviewer: Jessica Ruby
One question I've asked a lot is,
"What is a big challenge you want to overcome,
something in your life that you want to do?"
because that tells me a lot about that person,
and very often it's not directly related to the job,
and that's even more revealing.
So, that would be the question
I'd definitely ask.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.